I love how even though I tried to pick a
non-nerdy data one it actually
underneath the hood was a nerdy data one
you're like the you're a data hammer and
the whole world is just little nails
that you're just trying to hammer with
your you know like but dude this is the
best business in the data like a vacuum
you're the data Dyson that's just taking
in this data from everywhere you can
yeah
[Music]
man Founders are you like a lot of times
not good at explaining what they do to
idiots
so can I do it can I so all right I'm
gonna make you look cool I want to be
your wingman all right so you run a I
don't know if you call it software or a
data business but people pay
subscriptions and uh your your company
CBN sites you're now getting close to
100 million a year in Revenue which is
like a huge accomplishment hundreds of
employees as well and
basically and this is the part that's
kind of hard to understand for someone
like Sean and I because we haven't run
like really really huge companies but
basically when a company that has a
thousand people have to decide what
software they have to buy like let's say
it's just like some customer support
software or payroll or something they
need to do tons and tons of research to
make sure that the business that they're
going to pick the vendor they're going
to pick like will stay in business or
will be around for 10 or 20 years things
like that as well as a bunch of other
information and you have crawled through
what you call Dirty data so all this
data out there exists but you just put
it in a bit bits of software that make
it really easy to digest and understand
so a person can make a right and smart
decision and they pay you like 30 or 50
or 150 000 a year to access all that is
that right sounds about right yeah and
more importantly
fan of the show and prolific idea guy
before this episode before we did this
episode he sent over a Google sheet that
is
77 rows of
random startup ideas which just tells me
you're you you are you're one of us and
um so this is great you made our job
really easy we have a bunch of ideas we
can go through uh there's a few kind of
interesting CV Insight stories that
you've blogged about in the past I want
to talk about but let's do those at the
end because uh I think the ideas are
going to be a lot more fun
Sean one of the reasons why he's fun you
said that he's one of us because the
idea thing that's true he's also fun
because even though he comes off like
this like polite guy who's like uh
introverted he's a [__] a Nine's a
[__] his Twitter is hilarious he
always he writes this famous newsletter
to like 500 000 people now and he signs
it with like I love you and in his
Twitter the bio says um please buy a CB
insights subscription I owe people money
and like he always does like he kind of
pokes the bear a bunch in his stuff so
he's got the he's got a really cool
attitude
um but hopefully we'll get that out of
you yeah yeah exactly yeah my kids were
uh my kids were excited that you called
me a [__] so I appreciate that one
you're welcome uh all right so here we
go uh Sam you put your favorites on the
street I put my favorites what's
interesting to me is we have almost no
overlap you uh only maybe two out of the
ten that you put down there were my
favorites I had completely different
ones I'll tell you why I say we take
turns where we say tell us about blah
blah like the little the little three
set three word tagline and he gets to
pitch it and let's react and let's try
to get through a bunch of these so we
might go on random pan just or drill
down but like let's in general try to go
uh you know an inch deep on each one of
these for now
you want me to go first yeah you go so
the reason why I highly basically
everything I highlighted so CB insights
interest me because basically you're not
coming up with any data you're just
organizing data that already exists and
really easy to understand ways and then
you're selling it at high fees and I
think that's like the greatest business
model on Earth and you've listed out a
bunch of ideas including like six or
seven that were more of these like data
things data so you had one in there
called sawdust data and you have
examples you're like you can look at
what the government does like the
government has all this data you can
make that clear and easier to understand
for people
um
both the sawdust data as well as the
government data products what do you
mean by all that
yeah so Solace data is
people create products and sometimes the
residue of that product is actually
really interesting data right and so
that's the sawdust from the data and so
it's basically taking that exhaust and
so I'll give you a couple of examples
right you have
I'll just and I don't know if these are
businesses already but you know
OpenTable and resi have all this
reservation data
I wonder if you could take that data
exhaust and sell it to real estate firms
right and they'd be you know hey like
reservations are down this area is not
as hot maybe this this retail space is
going to be on the market soon because
this restaurant looks like a dog right
that might be one area you know I think
I met somebody who has uh dog collars
like a like a Fitbit for dogs right five
EFI right and so you could take that and
probably sell that to Pet Insurance
Underwriters right so it's like it's not
your core business it's this residue
that comes off of your business that I
think you could do interesting things
with
um it's another example like procurement
management system so kind of this like
esoteric enterprisey thing but if you
have all this spend going through this
procurement management system at your
company could you go and sell that to
hedge funds on like hey this company's
you know uh average contract values
going down or it's getting a lot more
seats sold this year right and so can
you take again not your core business
and I don't think companies are really
good at monetizing this on their own so
it's basically building this platform
that goes to these companies and builds
these data Products off of their sawdust
that makes sense with the the business
that Sean and I are and we're in
newsletter business like people have all
these questions but it's kind of broken
down into just a cute few things which
is just like figure out what content you
can give people that they want to read
every single day and then figure out how
to acquire users for profit profitably
and that's basically that's 80 of the
business what's like the 80 20 thing for
these like data businesses is there is
there or or rather the 80 20 for making
messy data clean data and make it a
product that people like
the messy dated a clean data thing
that's just like you have to have a pain
tolerance that's all that is right and
so I think this is why this is actually
I think why CBI has done well is like
we've had a bunch of Valley companies
come in and they want to Splash machine
learning on it and like you just have to
get into an Excel spreadsheet and clean
the data like that's just it and if
you're not willing to do that nasty work
you're kind of dead I'd say the
businesses that work are I think like my
framework is variable SKU highly opaque
High consideration and so I'll break
that down so high consideration means
like somebody's taking risks or putting
a lot of money out there right it's just
like it's got there's some skin in the
game opaque meaning it's just hard to
find you know and I think if you go into
slack groups and people are like hey
does anybody know X that's usually an
asset class that's like opaque right
does anybody know who a good vendor is
for this or a good software provider is
for this and then the last one is
variable SKU which is like like a car is
a high consideration software purchase
but it's not really variable like it's
got a set of features you can compare
them on a grid and so the internet's
really good for that I like businesses
where like the variability of the SKU is
significant because you can't just put
it into a table you can't like an
iPhone's an iPhone is an iPhone but like
we are we launch yardstick like you know
I don't know a radiology software that
uses you know that AI reads Radiology
images like those are totally different
and so right that's like the framework I
use and so when it meets on those three
I think that's an interesting messy hard
business that's going to be a lot of
pain but like you could build a moat
around that all right Sean you want to
do it oh sorry you had one of your
columns so so I told you you have 77
rows so those are the different ideas
but then you had some columns one of
them was frame Frameworks or or
inflections and that was your that was
one of your your things opaque variable
SKU High consideration the other one you
had was Tiny But growing meshes like or
like inflection like it might be time uh
for that to grow is that is that your
other one that you look for in ideas and
we can give an example here of like uh
here let me grab one like you did this
representation media so you said extend
the Rebel Rebel girls book for other
communities and then your framework was
tiny bit growing niches so talk about
that idea and explain it with that
framework yeah so Rebel girls if you're
a parent of a daughter you might be
familiar with it so we bought this book
when my daughter was you know three four
and it's just like one or two page
stories of like famous women in history
so like Amelia Earhart Marie Curie Maya
Angelou and it's great like it's a it's
a really kind of inspiring book really
cool artwork that book is sold I think
5.5 million copies at like 20 so it's
like 110 million dollars and that's
probably dated right but I think there's
like this idea of like what I what I
call representation media right I bet
you could extend that to
uh I don't know like Hispanic
entrepreneurs or like autistic
scientists right like people want to
read about and see examples of success
in their communities and so I think you
could extend Rebel girls across a bunch
of different things and so that's the I
think that Niche is growing right like
people like you get these micro
communities that actually are pretty
large that would love to read about
themselves and receive good
representations of themselves
that's a great idea uh I've had the I've
had a similar idea because uh we get
gifted some books that are like uh I
don't know like Hindu religion book or
like but it was like the kids version or
something like that it's like the like
and it's like oh yeah if I'm gonna read
whatever you know Clifford the Big Red
Dog you know like is there is there
something that you know adds a little
bit of something from our culture or
religion like makes it easy for me as a
parent to like give them you know
something I want to give them while
still being entertaining and accessible
and there's actually just not much
that's out there for that so so I
definitely uh think if you added up all
those little all those little different
issues that's that could be quite big
yeah I mean I think if you kind of on PC
if you found a story where the
protagonist was like a little white kid
like make it a little brown kid make a
little black
you know like modify the story a bit and
like that's a winner right because like
kids love seeing like oh that kid looks
like me that's dope right and so like
you're Off to the Races there I don't
think it's that nothing's hard it just
takes some work but yeah dude that's why
my that's why my wife loves Kim
Kardashian she like sees him she's like
oh hey look they got fat asses too
[Laughter]
dude fat a good way by the way back in a
good way when I met uh the comedian
Hassan uh minhaji we he was like doing
his live shows and I told him I was like
you ask me something like oh what would
you do with if with my business if you
were me and I was like dude I would stop
this like live touring thing that
comedians do like this is so painful
you're on the road like I don't know 40
weeks out of 52 in a year I wouldn't
want to do that I was like you got to
create a Broadway show I was like create
like the next Hamilton and then that
goes on tour right touring is a great
business but you just don't want to be
the guy sitting on the stage I was like
use your creative and comedic genius to
do that it was my kind of big idea for
him he's all right what's the show
and I was like ah dude I don't know now
now I'm out of my all right and then the
next like a week later I just sent him a
voice note and I go
Aladdin
but but Aladdin's black and he's like
what and that was my whole voice note
and then he goes
um what are you talking about I go
remember the Broadway show thing I go
it's Aladdin but they don't it's not
like Jasmine can't marry Aladdin because
he's like a poor guy no no Jasmine can't
marry him because he's black because
like you know her family doesn't approve
and he's like okay so it's just he's
black instead of poor and I was like hey
look when you say it that way it doesn't
sound that good but like I'm telling you
there's something to this idea of he
overcomes they fall in love and the love
wins and he's like all right yeah yeah
I'll add that one to the list
yeah that's what he said he's like stick
to podcasting Sean
oh yeah representation media all right
can I ask you about one this is actually
really fascinating and actually I think
can be a bigger business than than I
don't know if you think but bigger
business a lot of people think a daily
executive briefing email
yeah I don't I'm not sure how big this
one could be I think I I don't know if I
put in the sheet I said you have like a
dollar column which is kind of like my
indication of how big it is I think this
is like a great side hustle business
right so I when I worked at American
Express every morning our CEO would get
like a briefing from his chief of staff
right like you know here's what Capital
One did here's what city did yesterday
here's what visa did whatever and it was
like basically that person's job to like
scour the internet and like look at
financials and product launches and all
this stuff and there was a company that
cision bought called bulletin
intelligence which I don't think I don't
know how much they're doing with it but
it was basically that idea it was going
to be like your morning Chief of Staff
email and yeah I think this is an
awesome business that like somebody
smart and industrious can can build and
you I think if you go Niche meaning like
GO Financial Services because like if
you get AMEX like the CEO of Citigroup
like cares about Citibank cares about
mostly the same company so you can reuse
a lot of it and it's not just the CEO
it's all like their division presidents
and they're like geography like you know
heads and all that stuff so yeah I think
this is like and you know I'm sure with
generative Ai and stuff you could like
make this really like efficient but yeah
I think this is like uh tens of millions
of dollars business no I think you're
way off so
um have you heard of you guys know
Politico right yeah it's like a Politico
it's like a News website for DC all
politics but it's not from uh like a CNN
Fox News News perspective it's more so
like people who work in politics they
read Politico
whatever that's not interesting what's
interesting is that they sold recently
to Axel Springer for over a billion
dollars and where they got roughly nine
figures so 100 million plus of recurring
Revenue would they have this they have
this service called Politico Pro have
you guys heard of not have you heard of
Politico Pro
no I mean I know that's a premium offer
I don't know what's in it so basically I
think it's like a thousand a month I
forget the pricing so someone's gonna
like get on me but they had this they
had their pricing but the me it's
basically it's for if you're a lawyer
um or if you work in DC and you have to
know what type of laws are happening at
like a real rate like who you know like
hey the Senate is thinking about
changing this like because we heard the
senator say this in the news yada yada
well anyway they have these things
called Pro briefings and they send at
least one a day but sometimes more than
one a day and it's really fast short
emails and that's your briefing of
what's Happening that day with uh with
like a very very very Niche thing so for
example uh they have a segment just for
pharmaceutical uh companies so if you're
a pharmaceutical and you want to know
right away what's happening with the new
laws uh or if you want to dive deeper
and read about researchers or if you
just want to have a conversation with an
analyst you spend thousands of dollars a
year tens of thousands of tens of
thousands of year and that's basically
what you're getting is this briefing as
well as a few other things they scaled
this business to north of 100 million in
recurring revenue and it's pretty
fascinating and there's a few others
doing that and so I think if you could
actually pick the right thing whether
that's Pharma legal I don't know what
else there would be
um
uh all different types of Finance I
think you could actually build a really
interesting Daily Briefing business and
you could even have a user
say which companies they want to spy on
a little bit more than normal and I
think you could charge tens of thousands
of dollars a year for a subscription
like that yeah you can charge a lot for
this like these folks like as long as
you deliver quality in the morning when
they need it like yeah there's they have
sort of massive budgets and I think
bulletin had Bezos as a customer for a
while so like he was reading the
bulletin intelligence briefing every
morning so what's that company called
bulletin bulletin intelligence decision
bottom many years ago Dude the reason
why I like I like talking to you is like
you and I are some of the few people
that nerd out on there's like all these
data businesses out there so you and I
for years have talked about there's like
uh informa which is like a 10 billion
dollar market cap basically data and
trade show business then there's Euro
money which we've talked about another
publicly traded company there's a
decision which like is just kind of an
older company that no it just these
companies are just huge and they're just
not sexy so they're not talked about
with our Circle but they're crazy
fascinating to like learn about these
companies because their margins huge
yeah it's a I mean it's a build once so
multiple times kind of business right so
like once you build that data asset or
that info asset like you can keep
selling it so yeah they're great
businesses they're unsexy which is
always good because like then you don't
get all the smart people kind of trying
to come in and you know eat your take
your lunch money so yeah I like these
businesses a lot you had one on here
also that was the pricing data so it was
like go extract the pricing data from
every SAS tool and you know go to their
go to their website find the prices
organize all that information for things
where it requires a demo quote like I
don't know send a you know five dollar
an hour employee through that process
collect the pricing data now you have it
now you can make that visible where they
are hiding it on their website and you
basically have a giant what like a
search engine or a database of
of okay if I want to use some email you
know send software here's the here's how
the prices compare across them is that
what the idea would be for that yeah I
think the idea there is I think you
should start with public SAS pages and
you figure out how to crawl them or you
just you know M turkm or something uh
and then yeah email service provider
what's the pricing what are the features
I think the real killer there which is
you know maybe borderline is like you
actually because a lot of Enterprise
companies don't put their pricing on
their page so you hire somebody who goes
and pretends that they're a customer and
gets the pricing and then that's really
really valuable right because like now
if I'm because pricing's like a dark art
in B2B you're like yeah sounds good
right and like everybody's got opinions
and nobody has data so I think you could
actually do something really interesting
there like long term if you actually
called companies and got that pricing or
talk to their customers and you get
their pricing but that's actually the
tagline it was the tagline on your
website which is uh
without data you're just another idiot
with an opinion or something like that I
think dude that's great it was great
right I don't know do you guys use that
are you we don't use that anymore I
think we we still use like in God we
trust all others gotta bring data like
so we'll use that in some
who uh who comes up with this stuff this
is you or this is someone on your team
who's like the witty copywriter these
are just stolen from other people who
are it's like a quote the idiot wants a
quote I think right I think both of
these are like you know somebody like
some luminary and you know we we
footnote them in small print and give
them credit uh do do you think that you
guys being kind of silly is a leg up or
do people criticize you
yeah I mean we get some criticism but
honestly like B2B is so mind-numbingly
boring that like it's it's great as a
way to stand out but you know I I tell
the team like you know love us or hate
us you should have an opinion on us and
so that's the general theme right
because most of it's like pretty vanilla
and you know just kind of like jargony
and so yeah it's been it's been I'd say
a net positive for us but we've lost
some customers over stuff we've said
that offended them and what like what
you know we did a ranking one of VCS
once and we said a specific firm was
losing in the ranking and it was just an
objective thing and they were like we're
canceling our subscription immediately
right and uh
um what a loser move of them it just
proves my point oh you don't you don't
want access to data now you got you got
your feelings hurt and you canceled your
own your own data pipeline you're like
you're down another Peg
uh so we've had you know that and some
people don't like you know I think when
Trump hysteria was going we like
sometimes put an infographic with him in
it and like we didn't have an opinion
but it was just like you just him and
Elon Musk like if you mention them it's
this like lunatics come out right and so
like uh and so it's good for engagement
but it is definitely like a little bit
it can be odd like you say something and
people just like they've you know it's
it's a cult and people go kind of crazy
like I you you all you're a really good
writer and or whoever's writing is
really good and you guys always use
things like um your headlines are really
good but then there's like just phrases
all over like it's built into your
culture like in your annual review we're
like hey we did pretty good for a
company that isn't lighting money on
fire like the rest of the VC world
they're like just like little phrases
like that it just makes it stand out and
I think that that makes you have a voice
and you guys are actually pretty good at
that yeah and I appreciate that I mean I
think it's you know it's partly for the
external Market it's partly for the team
right like you're selling B2B software
and so sometimes that can be like you
know if you're 22 out of school it's
like hey that's not super inspiring and
I don't know exactly what that looks
like and then once we can show them we
can have personality we're in the tech
economy which is interesting so yeah it
works you know we screw up a bunch of
things but that's been good for us if I
was going to go out there and do what
you said of getting all the data and
like hiring people to call and actually
get uh quotes who would I sell that to
on the software pricing yeah
I think you go to product teams at
software companies and say like you know
or your CR Chief Revenue officers and
say like hey like you know do you know
how you came up with your pricing like
you know and here's what your peers are
pricing at and give them like a snippet
and give them a taste and be like hey we
have all this other detail behind right
how much would you charge
uh
I mean I don't think you start anything
with like crosstalk big companies and
like you start at you know twenty to
fifty thousand dollars right like it's
easier to go low than to start low and
go high we just um you just handed
someone listening a pretty solid idea
right
I I think that I I think the thing
people do is they under price we did
this in the beginning our first CB
insights when it started was 395 a month
and what you actually got was a bunch of
people who didn't know how to use data
who were a pain in the ass
right and so it was like your worst
nightmare it was people who churned
quickly who paid you little and who were
blowing you up on chat all the time for
support and then I remember meeting a
management consulting firm and they were
like hey can you add a couple zeros to
the price because like one your price
will look like a joke internally and two
I don't want to wait behind the guy
paying 395 a month for service so like
it price is a indicator of quality is an
indicator of other things Beyond just
like the core value of the product so
that was like eye-opening to me like I
was always like oh you know price low
and you know do all that and like you
know now we're we're orders of magnitude
higher than we used when we started
that's awesome Sean what do you got uh
let's do some non-data nerd ideas so
um I'm gonna pick it do the college
rankings one yeah yeah let's do the
college rankings one day would you call
it broke and busted broken busted
college rankings okay so what uh what's
the what's the inside here so I think
U.S news and World Report is sort of
like the preeminent college rankings
there's been plenty of coverage about
how that's a basic con right and like
universities do all this sort of
finagling to try to get higher in that
you know I look how's that work yeah
they pay or what what is what's that I
don't think it's that they paid I think
it's that like you know you've got these
like subjective criteria like uh you
know student to teacher ratio right and
so like
universities will like massage that data
so it looks good right and so like you
know that it's like a limited set of
factors
um and it's unclear how causal those
factors are to actually getting a good
education right and so I think you turn
that on its head well I think U.S news
and World Report you know I think in
like 2013 it was doing like 40 million
in revenue and now it has like again
LinkedIn 500 some odd employees so I I
gotta believe it's doing 100 million
plus in revenue and I'm assuming college
rankings is the number one thing so I
think the thing you do here is you
actually go to graduates of the school
and just ask them for their W-2s and
you're like how much are you making
right you just took on a bunch of debt
like does this place actually get you a
job that gets you paid or are you like
you know a server in a restaurant and
you got like your 200 000 in debt and so
I think you reach out to alumni go get
their W-2s and basically put a ranking
together of here's how much I paid and
here's how much I make when I get out
and if I'm a parent I'll care about that
I'll be like I don't really want to send
my kid to a school where their prospects
for employment are garbage
um and so I think it's like takes all of
the it's a very singular characteristic
so it doesn't take into consideration
social life and all that other stuff but
it's like I think it's pretty important
right especially you got all these
people like leaving school with you know
tons of debt so that's the way I would
do it and you have to probably pay those
students or ex-students a little bit but
I think it's pretty cheap and you
probably go like do like New York
colleges to start like start Niche like
don't try to be everywhere right out of
the gate like you know and then build
out from like concentric circles from
there
do you wanna like I don't know about you
shot but like what is
we're talking about some nerdy stuff
here but I I find it like crazy
fascinating because it's very clear to
see the opportunity here but what's
shocking
is like when you say oh I'm gonna go get
the data someone like me I would be like
um well I gotta go like Google it and
like find a database and you're like no
I'll just like hire like I'll use
Mechanical Turk you said earlier or I'll
just hire someone or I'll just like make
a ton of phone calls and just doing that
stuff I can get interesting insights is
and is that really how A lot of this
works and and the beauty of that
business is 99 P 99 people out of 100
won't do that work
so like once you built the data asset
like most people will think it's cool
and they just won't do it like the other
one that I like which is I don't know if
I put on the pages you know I was uh
trying to get a pool bill at my mom's
house and like pool pricing is just like
it's opaque highly variable and high
consideration and like I have no idea
what to pay for a pool like some kid
should just go door to door at every
person's house that has a pool and just
be like how much did you pay for your
pool and like get the specs and then go
find out and then find out what do they
pay per month for cleaning and whatever
I don't know what a pool requires and
like literally build the database of
like
that's a great idea who's in North
Jersey here's what it costs so like yeah
because that's what people Google too
right like uh you know pool pool cost
and then my city right that's a that's a
a term that people will look for or even
if they're just looking at pool costs
but you have their their city in the
headline they're gonna click that one
over the next one and then you go back
to the pool people and you're like Hey
listen I got this pricing next time you
want a bid you probably need to know
what your competitors are bidding so
like you can sell the data to both sides
right like but it's definitely like it's
a perfect side hustle like you know it
would be like a thing that I you know I
hope my kids will like just go do this
like door to door and go get data I love
how even though I tried to pick a
non-nerdy data one it actually
underneath the hood was a nerdy data one
you're like the you're a data hammer and
the whole world is just little nails
that you're just trying to hammer with
your you know like but dude this is the
best business in the data like a vacuum
you're the data Dyson that's just taking
in this data from everywhere you can
yeah I mean I love that business and I
actually think like not to get off on a
digression but I think this whole GPT
thing is actually going to make private
data like that much more valuable
because like you know before it was like
oh I'll give you my data and you'll just
link to me and I'll get Google but like
like that's all going away I think and
so like having access to private data is
going to be really valuable so yeah I'm
I'm extra bullied and do you look at
like for example the um the pool one is
a good one because it's probably not the
pricing's not probably changing all the
time whereas maybe the college one you
got to redo the the data collection
every year in order for it to be
accurate like for example in the content
game or the media game which me and Sam
think a lot more about is like if
anybody can do really well with
Evergreen content that's so much better
that somebody's doing what we were doing
daily daily emails where it's disposable
and you got to recreate the product the
next morning otherwise there is no
product and so do you think about that
when it comes to data like either the
ease of collection or the longevity of
the collection like really makes the
idea more valuable versus less
yeah I mean I think
you probably want data maybe
counterintuitively that requires a lot
of refresh right because like that's
what keeps people subscribing right if I
can get the data once and it's good for
three years it's like all right I'll get
it I'll churn I'll come back to you in
three years when it changes when it's
actually a little bit more when there's
a little more volatility to it it's like
hey I need to know what's going on
because like my business might suffer or
what have you in the case of the pool
when the pool owner is only going to buy
it once right but you know that but
that's okay right because like you could
sell those leads to pool people you
could sell that to pool cleaners like
you could do all sorts of interesting
things with it right and so like it
doesn't have to be you're selling the
data you could build advertising and
Lead gen and other businesses off of it
for sure
okay I got one that there's no way this
can be a data one
a McCormick's spice competitor
yeah I don't this one I don't have a lot
it's just you know I think I have a
column called zone of excellence and
this one's out of my zone of Excellence
uh look core mix is like this
multi-billion dollar spice company
if you open up your spice whatever
cabinet like there's probably like these
spices with like a red top right like
that's all McCormick's right 24 billion
dollar company wow in sales in sales
public company yeah so it's just like
like you know why isn't there like the
I don't know the apple of black pepper
like I don't really know how to do this
[__] right but like right like what's
the what's like well I think for this
one you're you're right you can go
either higher end or you know just the
more fun look at just branding packaging
design and influencer most importantly
so like who is the uh you know the
whatever the Martha Stewart of YouTube
that you can partner with that can be
the face of a brand like this right like
who who has that kind of brand and
gravitas that can get into a Target or
uh or the store shelves at supermarkets
uh to compete with something like this
and I think that's that's the way I
would go if I was going to do this yeah
100 I think the thing that's interesting
about this and I don't know anything
about McCormick's is like the bundling
like you know if you buy salt you need
pepper if you need pepper you might be
needing oregano and you might need
whatever flakes that they sell out there
right and so yeah you could just keep
stamping this out across like every
spice category but yeah this is not one
this is outside of my zone of Excellence
so I ain't doing this one but I like it
they own everything I didn't realize
this have you guys ever have you ever
seen this protein bar at gas stations
called Tiger's Milk
yes they own this bar it's the worst
looking like it's basically a label it
looks like it was like drawn by Kenny
Powers or like it looks like if Power
Rangers ate a protein bar this is what
they would eat and it's just like it's
called Tiger milk and it has a it has a
face of a tiger and it's like the
protein bar they own that they own a
bunch of different stuff this is awesome
I yeah I have I totally should have um
hell they owned Frank's Red Hot that's
my favorite so yeah what a what a
company I didn't I didn't realize that
these guys were what they are that's
wild man they're created in the 1800s
yeah I mean yeah they're just you know
brand recognition and everybody knows I
mean if you go to the spice aisle it's
all that like they just own the whole
thing right so you got to come up with a
distribution hack here but that's you
know Sean that's probably more your
world than mine but yeah for sure can I
ask you a quick question different from
my ideas but about money so I'm not
gonna you can say it if you want I'm
gonna assume that you own a a chunk that
you are on paper worth mid to high low
to low to high hundreds of millions of
dollars
have you taken any money out of your
company or has your only income for the
last I think you said 10 years you've
been running this just been like a a
normal mild salary
yeah so I didn't I didn't pay myself for
the first four years so when we raised
money then I basically took my back
salary and then since then I've not uh
not taken any money off the table so
yeah I'm I'm foolishly long or
brilliantly long CB insights we'll see
what we'll see how things play out but
yeah I'm all in were you wealthy before
you started the company like did you
have Banker wealth so just no no no I
just you know I got married right before
I started the company I told my wife
when we were dating that I don't want to
work at a big company anymore and we're
gonna like there's gonna there's gonna
be some lean times and so she was down
and so I just saved religiously like we
didn't go on vacations with friends and
just like you know and it was always
like awkward because they're like oh do
you want to go somewhere and I'm like oh
I'm super busy but because I just was
like no I don't have money so yeah I
just saved like crazy I'm busy I'm busy
being poor right now so I can't go sorry
I'll check the calendar when I'm not for
I'll start going I just saved a ton of
money and then yeah for the first like
two years of CBI just paid for a small
team out of my pocket and then we
started generating Revenue but wait why
haven't you taken a few million bucks
just off the table just to make your
life a little bit better it wouldn't it
would have no material output yes okay
yeah and by the way just so we have
numbers you basically have only made I
imagine
middle hundreds of thousands of dollars
a year in salary is that right
yeah I mean I'm I now get paid like a
fair CEO salary right so I'm not like
it's not like one of these big public
company guys but like um yeah I think
I just we've been really focused on the
business and like I just think it's a
giant opportunity and candidly part of
the reason we didn't raise in the
beginning was because I don't think I'm
good at pitching
and I also worked in Venture and I
didn't like want to work for my investor
right like that was always like a very
guiding principle of mine like you know
when I look at s1s of companies that go
public and I'm like you know the founder
owns like five percent I'm like that's
just like that's a backwards calculation
yeah probably you know should have could
have taken money off over the course of
time uh right now would not be a good
time to do that given where the markets
are so I figure we'll just keep growing
out of this current sort of malaise that
we're in and then you know opportunities
sort of tend to present themselves even
our fundraise was like a customer sent
us a term sheet over email
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
tell the story of the of tell the story
of the guy who offered you 100 million
dollars via DM uh how did that go you
know I get some interesting DMS on
Twitter and so somebody offered 100
million you know I think this guy was
broke as a joke but it was still funny I
said uh you know not interested not
looking to sell and I think then the
email chain kind of devolved from there
where he was like you know I'm gonna
build a competitor and put you out of
business and uh yeah it was good
I don't recall I don't remember it was
like some you blurted out of the thing I
blurted out yeah so so he sends this DF
you posted the DM screenshots it starts
like hey here's who I am really
interested uh you know in partnering or
an acquisition uh let's talk please call
me and then you're like thanks yeah not
even thanks THX right just like the the
short thanks
um not for sale nice and he goes and
then he goes how about a partnership and
then he just keeps going and he's like
here's how about this I'll give you 100
million dollars for the business you are
now your fiduciary responsibilities is
you have to present this to your board
you know
um you know that let's go and then you
go you go okay interesting strategy uh
best of luck and he goes so do you
accept the offer
and then he then he devolves into all
right then I'm gonna create a competitor
have you seen this competitor launch is
he uh is he in your lunch yet or what
surprise surprise we're yeah we're
tracking religiously to see when this
launches
you should have him back be like hey
how's it going man uh curious about the
law of details yeah yeah now that was
that was atypical I think most of my my
DMs are are nice but yeah that one was a
little a little out there what would you
do with the money now if you sold
um
I mean
I think the thing I do is I want to
build a school of entrepreneuring
like I think education is broken uh and
so I think like kids should just learn
how to build businesses and not go to
college and so that's what I do and I
think there's a bunch of colleges that
are struggling that I could go buy like
a plot and build like a dope campus for
for a bunch of like high achieving kids
and we'll just like go figure how much
would that take I have no idea I have no
idea this is like but you'll have it
this is my distant dream but yeah I
think like I just read a great book
called the case against education uh
that kind of breaks this down and it's
really interesting and uh yeah I think
it's like I think there's an interesting
thing to be done there and uh and then
yeah I'd love to like do some stuff in
India along that lines but yeah this
will be my last
true startup I've I've looked into a
bunch of uh I have like alerts set for
colleges for sale because I had a
similar dream and idea at one point in
time I haven't I now don't want to do
this but uh it's amazing you can buy
full college campuses
for
sometimes single digit Millions
sometimes just like 10 to 15 million
dollars
it's crazy like which ones it has to be
less than the replacement cost of just
the buildings and the land on the in in
this these places so so I am not sure
why and these are accredited
universities that a lot of them are are
they start as just like they do one like
things like just cosmetology or just
whatever there's like there's like those
those are really cheap those are like
you know 1.5 million you can have a you
know University a college that does that
all the way up to here's a campus in New
York for this like small liberal arts
college that's not doing so well and
like you know for 15 million dollars you
could take the whole thing and um I'm
like is there like a Marketplace for
that is there a Zillow for bankrupt
universities
uh there should be but there's uh this
one website called deal stream that
happens to have most of them that I see
um so deal stream will send me emails of
one like you know multi-campus beauty
school here you go um you know that just
got this email two days ago what made
you sour on this idea Sean
uh just like the lifestyle component I
was like would I like would I want to
actually if I was gonna do this it was
like okay I'm gonna basically go be the
dean of the school and I'm gonna like
basically this will be my baby and I
will make this great and I was like oh
it's a lot easier to just like have a
business I could just do on my phone and
my laptop you know four hours a day and
not worry about this and just hang out
with my kids and and you know have fun
and so I was like okay yeah there's an
all-in version of Entrepreneurship that
I'm no longer like super interested in
because that would require
um you know same thing like I'd rather
do this podcast than go speak at events
I think in the last three years I got
invited to speak at maybe 150 events and
I've said yes to two of them right like
you know so it's like you could make
good money and grow your audience doing
this but nah seems like a lot of work
you know I think I'll try to just win
the way I want Sean have you ever um
have you read the blog post that Anon
made years ago about I think your father
or someone in your family got sick and
they couldn't run their Factory in India
anymore and you had to go did you have
to run the factory right now his dad
yeah my father passed away in April 2017
and so he had a chemical business in
India and uh yeah you know like he built
it over many years and and like I was
like all right I can't just let it go to
zero so I ran it while I was running CBI
for about 18 months the the title of the
blog post is how to manage and sell a
company in an industry and a company and
a country you don't know
and uh it's kind of great it's like a
full like full-length sort of like
here's the whole thing
um do you want to tell like the short
version of the story and then people can
go read the blog yeah I mean so uh he
died on April 17 2017 and as we're going
to cremate him we're Hindu and uh this
worker from the factory comes up to me
in Hindi my hindi's pretty weak but I
understand it and the worker was
basically like in you know what's going
to happen to us right and I was like you
know I'm like a mess but I was like all
right I guess like there is this thing
and my mom and him basically built this
business over 20 years you know kind of
like a small Chemical Company like
nothing what's that mean gargantuan uh
in terms of size no or chemical what's a
chemical oh it was like a it was um
it was it's in a sector called Fine
Chemicals it was a raw material that
goes into perfumes and like uh flavors
and fragrances right and so he built it
one of three manufacturers in the world
that could make this product it was a
really finicky product
um and like I'm like all right I guess I
gotta run this and like my dad was like
a mad scientist like off the chart smart
and I'm like I'm not that right and so
uh so I'm like okay what do I do here
like because I don't if something goes
wrong in the factory I can't help so the
only thing I can do is probably try to
bring in more business so I just went
online and like cold called every large
Chemical Company that's in this space
and I was like hey we make this product
if you ever need it like come you know
come talk to us so we had like our best
couple of quarters ever when I was
running it and luck because you were
doing outbound and he wasn't doing any
or he just wasn't doing it well my dad
was just like he was a sign he was like
a product guy so he's like the best
product will win right and like put this
put picture up on the YouTube channel of
the blog post where it's the side of the
building it looks like and it just says
on one side good quality and then
there's a giant equal sign and then it's
just good business and that's like it
looks like as is that the side of the
building as you approach to walk in it's
like hey reminders I was entering the
factory yeah good quality equals good
business
[Laughter]
Times New Roman font oh my gosh this is
awesome
but yeah I was just like I can try to go
sell because I can't help on the
technical side the team he had assembled
was awesome so they've kept the factory
running you know got had good sales
people kept reaching out to buy it you
know a lot of them like you know when
somebody once a proprietor dies like a
lot of Bottom Feeders show up so I was
just like trying to make sure that these
weren't those people because I want to
make sure the team landed on their feet
and then yeah just navigated through it
I met a banker was representing this
buyer they were above board people and
yeah after 18 months for a while because
I'm like insanely ambitious I was like
oh I'll have like CBI as the data form
and I'll have like this industrial arm
and we'll build that and then like you
know it'd be a [__] Tycoon yeah well
I mean for it you know and then I was
like telling my wife I was like yo we
gotta have more kids because like if we
want to build you gotta like you gotta
have a lot of kids to like take this
take all these uh These Arms of this
industrial conglomerate up and she's
like you're insane and then uh and then
yeah like 10 weeks here or is six weeks
here 10 days in India like I mean yeah
like that was brutal so then I was just
like all right I gotta sell this and
then I was fortunate to sell it and the
team is still all there and yeah
everything worked out so what did you
sell it for uh I can't disclose a good I
mean like a good amount
yeah it was it was you know I wasn't
optimizing for the dollars I was
optimizing for a clean deal to a person
who would not fire everybody that my dad
built the business with so you know so
I'm sure I could have gone to somebody
else who would have like torn it down
and you know done other things with it
but I felt really good about these guys
so yeah I think it like it achieved
non-financial objectives that I think
were more important to my mom and to me
than maybe the financial objectives this
is a really really good blog post that
you have and it kind of got lost over
the years you guys got to share this
again more
yeah yeah I mean it was uh yeah it was
you know the team at CBI I got to give
him credit like I mean I was kind of an
absentee CEO for a little bit and they
like kept trains running on time so yeah
it was it was a it was a good uh a good
thing to accomplish I was glad glad you
had some like takeaways on the m a
process uh I'm curious I'll just read
the headlines but you could decide which
one of these you think you have a strong
point of view on or strong message to
deliver here so you said should I have
hired an investment bank and you were
like I didn't have one I represented
myself maybe I should have uh you said
don't let lawyers run the process so
lawyers are often trying to mitigate
risk but it's easy to just like have
everybody get entrenched in like you
know risk management and not actually
have the deal go through uh don't sweat
the small stuff
uh quote the industry standard is a
phrase to watch out for so give me your
thoughts on one of these the industry
standard one I think is like the one
that like I hate because like
people only use that when they can't
justify the term they just say like oh
no but that's just industry standards
how we do things we always do things
that way there's no such thing as
industry standard right like if it's
it's if it's good for you then it's what
you should aim for and that you know
it's some somewhat counter to the sweat
the small stuff thing so you don't want
to negotiate on every little thing but
when I hear it's industry standard like
my ears always perk up because it's like
somebody's like trying to get one over
on me on this right or they're just
trying to like make it the sweetness
under the rug so I think that's an
important one uh you know sweat the
small stuff I think like put some stuff
in that you want to negotiate on that
you don't care about that you're just
willing to give on right but like you
know just don't make the pain you know
don't make the negotiations super
painful in all regards on Bankers like I
think for this deal it didn't make sense
to use a banker and I have I mean with
CBI I have a bunch of data on like what
comps are and all that stuff so I had it
was good enough and it wasn't a big
enough deal that I wanted to like cut
into somebody for you know five seven
percent you know if CBI was doing a deal
now like we'd absolutely have a banker
because I I've definitely seen like the
value of what a great Banker offers
um but yeah I mean I think the the
industry standard stuff is probably the
thing like anytime you hear that I think
an entrepreneur should like just wonder
like okay why are they just pushing for
industry standard in this particular
area because it usually it's always
industry standard to the benefit of the
person across the table it's never
industry standard and good for you uh
and so that's one I would definitely
push on
can we um one thing happened over the
weekend Sean that you and I had talked
about and I actually think it's a good
time to talk about it now because I have
a feeling that anan's gonna know a
little bit about it do you remember uh
probably two months ago we talked about
this guy named Gautam adani I think his
name is you know what I'm talking about
you were like
I mean you're not to blame we were just
using the news and you were like this
guy's amazing look at what he's doing he
kind of looks like an Indian Mario guy
and he's like doing all this cool stuff
where he's like doesn't really care
about looking cool and he gives his
money away yada yada yada and now he's
like the third or first richest man in
the world the news was I think he had
gotten to second or third richest men in
the world and I didn't think most people
knew his name I says hey there's this
guy adani here's what he does and I
think we even said it I don't remember
really saying this but a lot of people
DM being like you guys called it
because news came out that there's like
some fraud going on or whatever with
their company and I guess we had said
something that was like you know either
this is just amazing or you know you
never know because of whatever I we have
to go back and listen I'm not sure what
the what the clip was but a lot of
people like you guys called that which
yeah people were saying that too and I'm
like I said thanks but I don't actually
remember I don't remember calling that I
do remember when I was reading about it
was a lot of people were like hey this
is kind of a shell game like he's
basically raising money he's raising
money in one company using the like
basic borrowing against another company
that he owns and that company's borrowed
against another company that he owns and
he had like so many entities that were
each sort of like
um the justification for the next uh in
terms of either the valuation or
borrowing money or whatever it was I
don't I mean this is a couple months ago
I don't remember what the details were
but I think we just said that as a
footnote it's not like we were calling
him out on anything I think people are
giving us a little more credit than we
deserved on that one so uh sorry to
interrupt you Samson yeah that's the
back that's a background so I think on
Friday Hindenburg research I think
they're a short seller so they they
short companies but they produce
scathing reports and they've done this a
dozen times I I can't I'm sure a non-new
products you probably know some of their
examples but they're just like known for
these really good reports well they'll
write and say this company we think is
total [__] here's why and then it
tanks and obviously they are financially
incentivized to afford to tank but as
far as I'm concerned I think some of the
researchers actually kind of spot on
sometimes and they have like a good
track record but uh not have you filed
this I followed it a little bit I mean I
like Hindenburg because I think like
there's like we live in like the age of
drifters and so like you need people and
I don't know if adani is but I think
like you need people like Hindenburg who
like you know or coffee Zilla or like
Wendover Productions or any of these
folks that are out there even on YouTube
who are trying to hold at least shine a
light on some of the griftiness that's
out there and so I you know I like what
they do in at a high level I don't know
if they're cased with the Donny's like a
good one or a bad one but yeah yeah well
basically they they said like the entire
company like there's a bunch of weird
things going on with it
um of all the like he they list all
these companies and each person that
runs one of the companies is one of his
like relatives or former executive so
it's all like kind of like uh uh
uh it's kind of like his cronies are
kind of like running everything and yeah
he's like loaning
money from other companies that he owns
and he's making the valuations of each
of those companies really high and so it
turns out it's basically like a little
ftx-esque where uh of just like similar
or entities that he owns loaning money
to other entities with the collateral
being a company that he values himself
among other things and so anyway I
thought you guys would have like an
interesting take on this because I don't
know you had spent a little time in
India you're in the finance world so I
wasn't sure if you if you had an opinion
there yeah no I don't have an opinion on
them I I will say like when you see like
org structures that are really
convoluted like you know FTX sir adani
or Enron before that like people always
like in the moment are just like oh
these guys are geniuses they figured out
how to move stuff and do X Y and Z and
then when you look back it's always like
no it was just like a giant shell game
you know Sean said like that that's an
interesting lens I think to look at
companies through and it's like the
Innovation isn't the product The
Innovation is like cap structure or some
weird thing it's like okay that's a
weird that's a kind of a weird business
to build right where like that's what
you're innovating on it's like companies
that innovate in HR right like I'm
always like you know they're doing all
these weird things it's like don't you
have to build a product like why are you
doing like 3.5 days of work and like you
know all this weird [__] it's just like
why don't you just work and like build a
product so have you been able to capture
uh or like catch any scams just or like
make any right predictions based off the
data that you guys have
yeah I mean we don't we don't publish
that stuff we usually send it to Media
right because we're not like a media
outlet but we'll find stuff where we're
like you know this company raised that
I'm not going to name but there was a
company recently that raised like at a
four billion dollar valuation and when
you looked at like the founders and you
looked at like the number of employees
and everything it was like something's
off here right and so you know and so
like we would send it to somebody and
say like hey like this looks odd like
you should go do what journalists do and
dig into it so we'll find stuff that's a
little
odd at times and then you know I think
the more interesting thing sometimes is
like you'll dig into filings of
companies after they've been acquired by
a public company and you see it's not
this isn't like a a scam or anything but
you see like you know hot company that
says they got Acquired and then you
actually see how much the public company
paid for them and it's like you know 1 8
of what they raised right and so like
you just sort of get it shines a light
on like what was a real success versus
what isn't I think that's probably what
we tend to see more you know people who
are want to do fraud or like if they're
good they're hard to catch period right
like it's just not something that is not
where we spend our time also some of
these things like the same exact signal
that later you look at and you say oh
man we should have known something was
off like you said at the beginning it's
a sign of of the genius of the of what's
going on like uh I know with FTX
um there was a bunch of things that now
people are like wow
this is you know those should have been
red flags but at the same time those
were the things that in stories they
were saying were like kind of the the
remarkable things about uh about them
like you know
um for example the
you know like oh the the you know they
all sleep in the same house and on bean
bags and whatever and now it's like oh
they had this weird like inappropriate
you know like sort of like group dating
thing going on but it's like uh before
that it was like these are just 20
something year olds that you know are
all like you know living in this Hacker
House that are making it happen it's
like no if on one hand it's one thing
and then then like you know after it's
exposed it becomes labeled as another
and I've seen this with I've seen this
many times where it's like oh you know
same thing Sam bankman freed is this uh
sort of like this this you know this
quirky genius and then he turns out to
be this sort of like uh you know this
drugged up liar it's like the same thing
he was doing before where he's you know
taking whatever you know Adderall or
whatever the hell he's taking in order
to uh you know stamp and trade it was
like yeah these guys are fueled by you
know you know Red Bull and whatever and
they're just working you know they're
Geniuses that are outsmarting everybody
in the market to like their game
gamblers who were Reckless and uh you
know were not making good decisions
because of you know their lifestyle and
what they were choosing to do and I've
seen this this happen before I remember
with Tesla
um there was a point in time where I
think Tesla had had like
10 or 15 different CFOs
and my friend had told me this because I
was like you know I'm reading a lot of
stuff online about how like
there might just be like some you know
there's a lot of smoke I don't know if
there's a fire but there's a lot of
smoke about Tesla not being in Good
Financial shape what do you guys think
what do you think about this am I am I
overreacting to these like conspiracy
theorists on Reddit and Twitter and he's
like well he's like I noticed something
interesting he goes I always have this
phrase follow the CFOs like the CFOs
know the health of the business and what
you never want to see was what was
happening with Tesla which was like a
rotating door of CFOs that would come in
for three to six months and then leave
and secondly
um like the new CFO it's like the shy 24
year old or 26 year old that's you know
now Tesla CFO wow he's amazing the same
thing happened at FDX I remember when we
we did we were uh they were sponsoring
us for something and the guy who was
paying us
um was their head of strategy and we you
know I didn't go on the call but I asked
by later I was like so was he like you
know super sharp or what was that guy's
story he goes yeah he's 24. he's 23
years old or 24 years old and he started
as whatever and now he's promoted he's
like the he's the head of strategy for
all of FTX and again it was like wow
that's crazy I guess they're just a real
meritocracy around there and they just
you know land of equal opportunity and
this guy just proved his Worth or it's
like no this is his college buddy he's
not going to ask too many questions and
he can just trust him to to do whatever
and say whatever right like these things
from the outside I remember reading
articles about this Wonder kid and uh
and then later it's like a bad thing and
you were right about the CFO thing with
Tesla at that time weren't they on the
brink
well people don't talk about that much
now but it did seem like they were on
the brink or you know
just you know narrowly survived either
either properly or improperly I'm not
sure but like later I remember one one
uh interview Elon finally admitted it he
he was like we were six weeks away from
like you know the show being over for
Tesla when they were having the model 3
production ramp and uh and he had said
something in a separate interview that
alarmed me as well which was about um
there was like some what's that famous
like green clean energy thing that Obama
funded like like the green New Deal or
something no it was like 600 million
dollars to soy Vera soy lent sorry
whatever I don't know some soyligen I
don't know what it was some company that
uh got a bunch of money and it failed
and like up until the day they declared
bankruptcy it was like we're we're good
I don't know what you guys are talking
about and
solyndra that's exactly right
and they asked Elon about that like you
know just clean energy get a bad rap
because of the you know the problems of
solendra and others people say it's hard
to make new tech work and all this stuff
and he said something in a in a separate
interview where he was like
what are they supposed to say as soon as
they if they ever admitted any weakness
the stock would tank and it would
guarantee their demise like they have to
say it's all good you guys are nuts
whether they are or aren't because the
other one is is it it it will tank their
stock and they will die for sure it'll
accelerate their death so then I was
like well you can't believe anything
this guy says about how Tesla's doing if
that's his mentality when they're you
know I'm reading these things about how
they might be on the brink he's saying
they're all fine but he even says that
that's the CEO's job in this situation
so now you know what to do and that's a
long story short about why I sold my
Tesla stock too early yeah I do think
like there's the signal that I look for
it's not in the data is like the
narrative when it's like a crazy founder
narrative like uh like they were in
Southeast Asia living in a monastery and
they talk about like their clothing
choices like that's always a weird one
right when it's like we're not gonna
talk about the business we're going to
talk about celebrity wear some like
moleskin t-shirt made from like you know
but it worked with Zuck
yeah but he wasn't like he built the
product to start he wasn't known for his
like weird I think it's the key thing
when you can't see the product or the or
the financials right like like for a lot
of these things where it's like is the
product legit and is are the financials
like visible right but but even then you
can't like you know FTX was a like a
real product that that people used and
the financials made sense at the time
that like they were obviously gonna
they're making money on every trade
right people doing a lot of crypto
trading how can they not make money
um you know it seemed like it would work
in both cases another example in the FDX
side they had 25 engineers
and I remember reading stories about how
he was just like yeah we create like
we're not like these Silicon Valley
companies with all this bloat coinbase
has like you know thousands of employees
we have a whole engineering team of 25
and we do more volume than them because
we hired 10x engineers and we we go for
extreme operational leverage and later
it was like
of course these guys had like terrible
security practices and all the stuff
like they didn't even have they refused
to even invest in engineering right it's
like the same story the two sides of the
same story once you once you know the
result yeah 100 I do think there's
signals when I don't think fraud but
there's signals right now that companies
are not doing well right so like you'll
see companies raise it a billion dollar
valuation and when we dig in we see like
the liquidation preference is 3x but
that stuff doesn't get reported right or
you see the cro or the CMO leaves every
six months kind of Sean's point on the
CFO like that indicates there's problems
it's not fraud it's just like hey this
company's not killing it the way
Outsiders might look at it I think
Fraud's a tough one I think under
performance and and companies that are
not doing well that's a lot easier for
us to figure out what's a company that's
impressed you that we most people don't
talk about because you guys see a bunch
of companies that are that are
interesting what's a company that's uh
kind of flies out of the radar but kind
of secretly crushes it and like a debt
and it's gonna be it's probably gonna
end up in the data World
um so let me think it's all right
um
I don't know if anybody
I will say like the area that I like
right now and I don't think these are
great businesses but I think like I
think are interesting is like the the
the folks that are
uh analyzing the grifters right like I
really like love this space because I
think there's something to be built here
like there are more media companies than
they are great big tech companies
um but there was like there's a couple
that like are digging into like pastors
and like the whole like Evangelical
Pastor world and like it's phenomenal
like the stuff that they do so like
that's probably the area I go down a lot
more in and then like looking at the
businesses of folks like Andrew Schultz
and folks like that like you know
because I think there's a lot to learn
from how they do marketing and how they
build audience so I tend to look at
businesses that I think we can learn
from versus like just like random sort
of businesses that are out there uh what
what can a boring company like yours
learn from Andrew Schultz
so the thing that so I think the thing
that he's done really well I I was
purposely insulting you in order to uh
make make the average listener be like
oh yeah I'm not that cool the thing that
he does really well is he doesn't just
interview other comedians right I think
he like he interviews other people who
are kind of adjacent to him right and so
what he does then is he keeps expanding
his audience and I think most other
folks like you know like I like Theo
Vaughn and Theo Von's like interviewing
other comedians right right but like he
interviewed Neil deGrasse Tyson and I
bet you that brought him a whole bunch
of new people right and so I think that
it was very funny yeah it was awesome
and so this sort of like Schultz
strategy of like adjacent folks I think
is really smart to bring in like the
Venn diagram is not as heavily
overlapped and I think like he keeps
building that way which I think is
really interesting and so for us like
it's always like who has an audience
that's not exactly our audience but that
has maybe a slight overlap and but would
those people kind of like us if they
knew about us right and so it's kind of
like thinking about Partnerships there
whether it's newsletter Partnerships or
whether it's you know research that we
do whatever it might be so yeah I think
like looking at what's happening in the
consumer side of media is always
interesting because that's where like
the Innovation tends to happen it
doesn't usually tend to happen in B2B
well dude I appreciate you doing this
you're fun to talk to Sean what do you
think we only got through maybe half of
the half of the short list ideas so uh
if people like this we should do a part
two and uh and do more do more of the
ideas thanks for coming on man this is
fun and uh appreciate you know that
you've been you know come I feel like
I've seen you tweet about the show you
know for a while now so you know that's
a really appreciate that that's one of
the cool moments of this doing this for
us is that people we respect if they
like our stuff too that gives you a
little extra juice a little extra wind
in your sales to uh to go out and keep
going because it's it's different than
just oh the numbers are going up but
numbers don't have that same kind of
like pull as you know
um somebody who you think is cool you
know liking your stuff and by the way
Adnan it's your fault it's kind of my
fault it's most it's part your fault
basically
I get like lots of messages a day but
like five of them a day it's usually a
young man in his 20s and he'll just
message me and he'll say let's [__]
that's all I get and the reason being
one time I was either on my way home or
in route to the airport and I was T I
hate flying so I take a lot of Xanax and
so that's the only time I'm ever
inebriated and I was very high and I
messaged you and I said I'm in your hood
let's [__] and you replied like
I'm down like
here's a restaurant meet me there
something like that and I told that
story and uh
now because of that I get I get a bunch
of men messaging me that
um living the dream Sam you're living
the dream someone's dream someone's
stream not my dream but someone's dream
yeah I'm living I'm living a person's
dream
so uh you're gonna play for that but I
appreciate you coming on and uh this is
fun we'll talk soon all right thanks
guys
foreign